now to the stunning toll the pandemic is
taking on the economy we just saw how
unemployment spiked in yesterday's jobs
report but other figures tell an even
darker story it is the number of people
applying for unemployment benefits 3.2
million americans applied two weeks ago
then that enormous figure more than
doubled to over 6.6 million last week
for more on this we are joined by CBS
News senior business analyst Jill
Schlesinger Jill I'm gonna start with
something that really stood out not even
just the numbers in reading from so many
economic experts the talk that this will
be more like the Great Depression than
any recession we've ever seen has been
out there can you give us any sense of
how that might look in our modern time
well first of all let's talk about
what's different and that is that we've
learned a lot of lessons since the Great
Depression so I know when people are
thinking about breadlines it's very
scary that's not what's happening today
we are throwing a lot of money at this
problem we are the richest nation in the
world and so we're not going to see that
but the reason we're going back to the
depression is we've just never seen job
losses like this ever and as you said
with 10 million people filing for new
unemployment claims over the course of
just two weeks let's put that in
perspective throughout the Great
Recession
there were eight point eight million
jobs lost over 17 18 months so this is a
sudden stop to not just the US but also
the global economy and so we're looking
back to understand how long it could
last and what we can do better this time
around
and those unemployment numbers certainly
are staggering right now I know talking
with a lot of people early on in the
process they had a hard time even just
applying for the benefits where are we
now with that well the state
unemployment systems are really over
overdone especially in those states that
were hardest hit early on so Washington
State in California New York New Jersey
these problems are going to be ironed
out and so what I want to remind anyone
who has been laid off or furloughed you
don't actually have to be a full-time
employee to collect unemployment that is
changed since we got the cares Act
passage you also should
that if you run into a problem online
try not to call you're gonna be on the
phone for hours if you need help with
your online registration for
unemployment benefits call your friends
get someone to walk you through it but
go ahead and do this because this is
part of your lifeline
that the state and the federal
government is providing so we just have
those numbers up on the screen looking
so looking at the March jobs report most
losses were in leisure and hospitality
as you look ahead to the April report
what are you expecting to see then
well economists are very concerned that
when you look at the report we just had
it's really for the first two weeks of
March and so as a result when the next
report comes out we could see millions
of job losses and I mean millions one to
three million some people or Act some
economists are predicting five to seven
million and you look at that sharp tip
when you look at leisure and hospitality
think about the restaurants think about
the drinking establishments think about
retail which is the next wave you know
the retail furloughs occurred in the
second half of March we now know
hundreds of thousands of employees of
retailers have been sidelined whether or
not they can come back anytime soon is
anybody's guess but I think that's the
next wave to see real problems in that
industry and Jill very quickly the other
issue here on Friday small business
owners did start the the process of the
Paycheck protection program but there's
going to be this massive influx now of
applications our financial institutions
and the government prepared to handle
that well they are ready right now and
we saw a lot of problems yesterday
there's promises that things will get
better if you got a if you got a message
that said you're not eligible try again
next week okay Jill Schlesinger thank
you very much